spearfishing in Hawaii I'm like a fish
out of water thank god I've got free
diving champ Kimmy for a guide she makes
it look so easy
[Music]
damn she's good despite my fetching
camouflage I can't hear a thing
[Music]
frustrated oh really
you're almost there that was a good fish
too how do you keep your breath under
such control because you're holding down
to the seabed got the other
[Music]
right hold my breath line up my sights
this is just like shooting fish and
about a very big Pacific Ocean sized
barrel
bingo I held on to the rock bed round
the corner just waiting for them to pop
up what a teacher it makes you want to
live underwater
it's that exciting you don't want to
come up I want to go back again
this is annoying did you grow up eating
fish like this my dad would go
spearfishing to put food on the table
and this is one of the main fish that he
fed us how cool beautiful so you could
literally eat this raw we always would
eat this fish raw this fish eats a lot
of seaweed and so it tastes different
all on different parts of the island
depending on what type of sea is growing
there thank you and it does taste a
little bit salty
a lot of times we add seaweed by flavor
with this fish it's already pre-seasoned
say it I mean it's like the perfect trip
to any fishmonger you'll ever go to your
entire life I didn't think it would
taste that good and my god without any
dressing without any chili or any soy
and so that's got me thinking now you
know do I don't make this this feast
Romilly around the fish locally or is it
meats right now honestly I was for for
choice want to see more for my uncharted
adventures please click here to watch
more clips